welcome back and restore another mr.
beast gaming video this is an exact
scale replica of area 51 I know because
I went to it this right here is a
government facility and this is where we
do alien testing and we have 100 random
minecraft players right here so here's
how this works we're going to open the
gate and let them raid area 51
every time they jump in this portal they
get points whoever has the most points
at the end of this video wins 10
smackeroonies dixie in points and I have
gathered you here today because I
recognize your guys names and I need you
guys help to let me win you guys are
both one it's my turn all right
5 4 get ready creepers agree the gates
are about to open - no 10 grand for you
left oh hey here's hey last time oh you
took dead boy Jedi's the one who want
the last one of these I'll try em he
just went 5 grand no oh all right I'm
gonna let poor Jedi through Chris sorry
sorry
oh is this home gonna be slick 360 oh
not again by me ain't nobody get Bobby
Oh creeper all guys now remember the
golden rule if the FPS merch on let it
through our dan has besmirch on let him
through he practically hand them the
$10,000 boys here we go no don't a few
don't let him through no bad Ravager you
do not kill people
oh my gosh stop lawn mower bird
Taylor pick left or right right all
right right it is
I'm blocking off a little bit of right
what's up lava okay here we go just make
a tunnel all the way to the border yeah
I'm gonna build it right now you guys
keep working I'm still my leaderboard
I'm catching up yeah right yet on the
leaderboard and then this way whenever
I'm done with the tunnel that'll be good
to go
no Chandler you killed the other guy
that one finger is good they don't need
it true
while we're mercilessly slaughtering all
these Minecraft kids I want to let you
guys know that side this guy PewDiePie's
editor is now editing for us as well we
put out this tweet asking for editors
and now scythe is our editor so we have
this save editor as pewdiepie sigh are
you editing this video yes it's me sigh
sigh what do you think of this video so
far it's an epic con system I'm
interesting so it's very interesting all
these people have a chance of 10 grand
except for that person and that person
oh you deserve to live you dodged it
and that person oh this guy has a
PewDiePie skin get out the way clear a
path for PewDiePie guys we gotta let
PewDiePie win since we took his editor
I'm literally just standing here
swinging and occasionally people
literally look at even movie dude look
they're literally just walking into it
that's the guy who won $10,000 so do us
part enough to avoid it run 1 is over
and parade is currently tied for first
place with Yoshi they are tied for
$10,000 and Dan who mine shows where
these mergers in third place should I
help him out a little bit alright boys
we gotta have a meeting meet on top of
central tower all right here's the deal
we are the government hmm and we have
alien secrets we must protect yeah then
why are so many people coming through
Taylor
start using explosive snowballs Chris
start doing literally whatever you have
to do Chris you're the FBI and you're
the CIA and currently you're both like
childs all right I'm making the money
printer go birth
you guys have unlimited funding open the
gates I gotta destroy
everyone's dying gates have been opened
no mercy
everyone no mercy get away get away get
away boy go take notes a grad no
cigarette note a grinding grinding
grinding grinding OH Kratz a lot are
going did you guys only focus on window
10 grand 10 grand 10 grand oh there's a
rim skin killer
Chandler carpet bomb the crap out of
them there's so many blazes on the map
the blazes dude you so much okay right
here come up here alright Chris here's
the new game plan we're gonna block off
the left and right with lava
we're gonna build a confusing maze in
the middle and that's the only path so
they have to solve the maze we're gonna
picture only the intelligent people win
all right where is save the maze for
next round it's gonna get so hard you
don't even understand Jimmy I trapped
all these people and now they just have
to die Carl did you dig a hole what is
this there's an underground hole stop
worrying about that no no no no let me
put my game the hole is gone bean game
barn come here boy
I'm killing every other person that
comes across you can pass you can I'm
the Guardian you can pass you can't we
can't let him get the aliens guys
there's too many aliens getting grabbed
the Big C has 340 aliens already I'm
really does enjoying hitting these kids
oh my god everyone keeps taking shots
for Jedi lawn mower gopher
that is the end of round 2 everyone
decide the next round is the final round
and we don't just want luck to be a
factor nah we don't want luck to be a
factor we want big brains we want
whoever has the biggest brain to win so
what we're doing is we're blocking off
the left side and we're blocking off the
right side and we're giving them very
complicated mazes they have to solve to
get to the end but but since this is the
third round every score is 30 points
instead of 10 so if they solve this
they're gonna rack up points quick and
possibly win 10 grand per round three
they have to complete this incredibly
hard maids or if they're the biggest of
the brain they'll find a little hole in
the ground here those are their options
let's see who does it for 3 to unleash
oh let's see what they do pink all right
boy we've already got some point dummies
going right we got lots of people little
do they know this is a dead end
wait oh my gosh I did block off this
time block off this side all right
I'm fixing it fixing fixing so we have
lots of people doing the maze did anyone
find my little path over here
Oh some people have figured out the path
on this side have they figured it out it
looks like they have okay these people
have used the big brains okay so we got
big brainers over here how are these
people getting through the villagers are
just destroying people wait they can
just walk through this oh look at this
pillager waiting for them oh this guy's
got big brain plays Chris let's block
off all paths that are not the tunnel oh
they're so mad they're so mad all right
all paths have been blocked off except
for the maze okay so we've got some
really smart people coming through the
sides right here and they're doing like
a strafe jump
oh wait Hales made it through she made
it through the lava and then she died
this maze right here is now the only way
through whoa
- earth is in first so he's going back
up the waterfall now he's gonna give it
one more shot a lot of people are
getting stuck in the swim in animation
cuz it makes you go faster but oh
they're bullying him they're pushing him
into lava wait they're literally ganging
up on him cos he's in first wait wait
where it early only going after him
you're trying to hit him out of the
water and all kinds of stuff where is it
losing up the water right now
yeah there is this smell this is the guy
in first place right here go go go
he's blowing it bro Carl are you
bullying him
oh they keep hitting it off yeah dude he
this is his chance for ten thousand and
random minecraft nerds keep pushing him
off there's one two minute left oh my
gosh we have a tie currently with one
minute remaining heinz ama is sprinting
through it he's dead it Dan gets the
dump right here he can win Oh No jump -
fell in the lava No ten seconds it's a
tie between zom todd on oh boy Levi or
Dan score
oh dude damn might just win Dan oh my
gosh did you see that the last second
the very last second Dan jumped in so
we're all on the same page I'm gonna
open the gates and whoever scores first
one time wins $10,000 that's it there's
a very complicated maze you ready
alright three two one go Santos finally
off to a good start
alright let's see oh he's going for it
he's gone alright Dan
what are you doing Dan think about it
smart you've got plenty of time map it
out map it out ladders up just push them
in the lobby just won $10,000 how many
hearts did you have half a heart I'm not
gonna really realize if you would have
just burnt for one second longer it took
a little bit more damage ooh little lost
ten grand
thankful can you give us a victory
screech are you turn do you have a
parent or anyone that you could just
throw on the mic so I can just let him
know I must give you a large stack of
cash
oh oh I'm so proud of for the I don't
know if that we saw subscribe to be
serviced is the best gaming mr. B's
gaming you heard the mischievously
scribe button right now congratulations